[Music]
france 5
but came to grasse
i think that thanks to the
perfumery industry would be disconnected from what
it was scramble since
anyway my name is jean paul joubert
and i am a rose producer moreover
since i  was born from the queen
my family was one of the first to
grow roses thanks to around
the 1840s 1850 the first trials
it is a most satisfaction all
start flowering and their flowering it is
time but today the
normal April day and the pickers the wind
can read us as soon as it's cooked
we go to a hangar we put them in the bags
and it goes to the industrial well it's
still a single line satisfaction of 2.2
to do  very,
very high-end production 1
rose growing that's what I do I'm going to
continue for a few more
years because I'm 62
my name is frédéric told me we're
really in a possible  destruction
of the rose in itself is obvious that
what theirs which gives a richness and
quality at the level of the facets that it is
extremely sought after so once
the three stages of washing have been
done daily there will
therefore be deliveries of roses and we will
accumulate in the evaporator  until you
really reach the last stage which
will be the concentration in the end to
hold the concrete
so it takes 600 kg to make one kilo
of extracts and I would say that 1.1 g a
small gram of extracts around 48
47  would therefore thanks to times in
essence to reassure not obvious for
against
[Music]
[Applause]
annoyance